françois bayrou le président du modem
est l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
ce rendez vous 2 public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse deborah claude sera
là tout à l'heure pour évoquer la marche
déjà engagé vers 2017 je ne parle pas de
la vôtre enfin je vous laisserai
répondre tout à l'heure et puis perrine
tarneaud évoquera dans la dernière
partie de l'émission votre combat contre
la réforme du collège et vous voilà
rejoints aujourd'hui par l'académie
française unanime mais on rend d'abord
hommage si vous voulez bien françois
bayrou un béarnais mieux même un palois
tony estanguet inquiets le champion de
canoë bien connu et qui porte la
candidature de paris aux jo de 2004 de
2024 et bien sûr vous le suivez un jeu
le suisse est incertaine amis c'est un
de mes proches et c'est quelqu'un qui
joue dont la vie de pour un rôle très
important et dans la vie sportive
française et internationale un rôle très
important c'est quelqu'un pour qui j'ai
beaucoup d'affection
on partageait son engagement pour la
candidature lui ni son frère et donc oui
je s'il juge que c'est jouable à ces
voleurs en juin alors je suis akbar
c'est eux qui ont étudié le dossier
j'ai des souvenirs de déconvenues je
suis pas le seul à avoir vécu avec un
peu de tristesse ce qui s'est passé lors
de candidatures précédentes
et j'ajoute que il est possible que
enfin je voudrais que ce soit toute la
france qui se trouvent concernés et pas
seulement l'agglomération bien sûr mais
parisien pourra peut-être des atouts à
faire valoir pour les épreuves de canoë
pour en particulier nous avons à pau
comme vous savez le comme vous le
rappelez un des plus beaux stades du
monde en matière d'eaux vives en kayak
canoë et je trouve que ça serait plus
heureux que ce soit toute la france et
pas seulement l'agglomération parisienne
soit la villa on est je vous pose la
question françois bayrou est vos
candidats à 2024 en tout cas je suis
candidat comme tous les palois à faire
que le stade d'eaux vives que nous avons
bâti est construit et qui est une
réussite
exceptionnel on va avoir comme vous
savez la coupe du monde en 2016 et de
championnat du monde en 2010 est donc c
est un des sites phares mondiaux puisse
en effet être utilisé dans le cadre de
ces jeux fabien dans l'actualité bien
sûr il ya la perspective d'un accord
enfin avec la grèce est ce que vous avez
d'ores et déjà envie de pousser un ouf
de soulagement
je verrai quand on sera au bout de cet
accord si vous voulez ce qui est à peu
près certain est juste c'est que
l'europe ne pouvait pas s'accommoder
sans rien dire d'une fracture d'un
éclatement d'un accident qui aurait eu
des conséquences négatives sur
l'ensemble de l'union et de l'euro alors
je reprends cette phrase parce qu' elle
n'est pas évidente pour tout le monde il
ya beaucoup de gens qui disaient écouter
laisser sortir les grecs
et puis se passera rien c'est une thèse
qu'on a entendu défendu par des esprits
quelquefois des esprits tout à fait
respectable une valérie létard d'état
absolument parmi d'autres et donc pour
moi ça n'a jamais été évident parce que
dès l'instant que vous laissez une
fracture s'établir et dès l'instant que
vous laisser un pays de la zone de la
zone euro faire défaut c'est à dire ne
pas payer ces gens ne pas remplir ses
engagements et ne pas payer ses dettes
à l'instant même la totalité de la zone
euro n'apparaît plus comme une zone de
sûreté
et quand de sécurité financière et quand
vous n'êtes plus de zones de sécurité
financière qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
très simple les taux d'intérêt montent
donc on arrive d'ailleurs à le nourrir
avec la grèce on a raison de d'éviter
autant que faire se peut l'accident est
la rupture
après est ce que ce sera durable étant
donné la situation actuelle
de la grèce qui n'est pas d'ailleurs
uniquement de la responsabilité de ce
gouvernement qui est aussi de la
responsable qui est sûr aussi et surtout
de la responsabilité des gouvernements
précédents
est-ce qu'on peut être rassurer
complètement je ne me rendais pas dans
les coeurs de ceux qui sont rassurés est
ce que vous espérez secrètement
finalement que la gauche radicale se
disent sur le plan qui a été proposée
qui est près d'être acceptée non j'ai
une alternance puis sera menée peut-être
y a de meilleur jeune génération rien
secrètement j'ai une conviction depuis
longtemps que j'ai exprimés y compris
sur tous les plateaux qui est que les
promesses que avait fait syriza et de
sipera ce n'était pas compatible avec la
nécessité à laquelle la grèce doit faire
face le l'obligation à laquelle la grèce
doit faire face pourquoi parce que ce
que je dis est une contradiction majeure
c'est le prochain et durer ce que je dis
pour la grèce est vrai pour la france
lorsque vous êtes un pays qui doit
emprunter pour vivre tous les jours
emprunter pour son train de vie
quotidien pour payer les salaires des
fonctionnaires les retraites quand vous
devez emprunter
vous ne pouvez pas aller voir les
personnes ne les banques auprès de qui
vous empruntez où les états auprès de
qui vous empruntez où la banque centrale
européenne que selon ce qu'on voudra
vous ne peuvent vous ne pouvez pas aller
les voir en disant je vous rembourserai
pas parce que dès l'instant où vous
dites je vous rembourserai pas à 7
minutes précise évidemment les taux
d'intérêt explosent
parce que vous allez pas prêter vous à
votre voisin 1000 euros si votre voisin
vous dit je te préviens je vais te les
emprunter mais je te les rendrait pas et
donc vous voyez c'est c'est toute la
limite des promesses le très souvent
dans cette question mais alors la
démocratie n'a plus son poids la
démocratie n'a plus à
sa liberté les peuples peuvent pas
choisir ce qu'ils veulent non les
panneaux peuvent ainsi réaliser ce
qu'ils veulent lorsqu'ils sont obligés
d'emprunter alors quand vous regardez ce
qui s'est passé ces derniers ces
dernières heures
françois hollande s'est montré plutôt
conciliant fin de compréhension pour la
grèce sans gay la merkel pour dire que
l'allemagne est le principal créancier
de la grèce a été plus intraitable eric
et que pensez vous de cette répartition
des rôles si l'ue répartition et
l'action du chef de l'état
enfin c'est lié il est un fait que vous
dites l'allemagne est le principal mais
la vérité que la france est engagée pour
la grèce a entre 60 et 65 milliards ce
qui veut dire 1000 euros par français
que vous êtes une famille de cinq
personnes
c'est pour 5000 euros que vous êtes
engagé en grèce et donc je soutiens et
je comprends la nécessité de ne pas
arriver à l'accident mais je dis aussi
que les gouvernements français sont
responsables de dizaines de milliards de
graisse de dizaines de milliards de
dettes qui sont engagés en laisse
est ce que cette si longue négociation
ne montre pas toutes les fragilités de
l'europe franchement françois bayrou il
faut des années puisque vous dit
effectivement que la crise a commencé
bien avant l'alternance à athènes pour
arriver à ce genre de compromis toujours
hasardeux et on n'est sûr de rien vous
le soulignez d'ailleurs les faiblesses
de l'europe
bonds les faiblesses de chaque pays
parce que dire les faiblesses de
l'europe s'est laissé croire ont laissé
entendre ou accréditer l'idée que ces de
l'europe que vient la crise de la grèce
c'est pas vrai la crise de la grèce
elles viennent de grèce ont encore
baissé
c'est un thème que les décisions ont été
prises c'est athènes que le trucage a
été organisée alors peut-être l'europe
un peu fermé les yeux 1
mais c'est à athènes le parmi les
dirigeants grecs et les deux
gouvernements successifs de droite et de
gauche qui se sont
qui se sont succédés à la tête c'est eux
qui ont décidé de truquer les chiffres
c'est eux qui ont décidé d'exposer leurs
pays alors maintenant qu'ils sont dans
l'erreur et ils ont toute leur place on
peut pas les chasser vous l'avais dit en
tout cas les engagements sont elles et
la solidarité et l ou plus exactement le
l'étroitesse des liens nous engage tous
d'accord alors je ne vous ai pas dit que
j'étais optimiste pour l'avenir de la
situation grecque chez paddy power
je dis que si on peut éviter l'accident
bien sûr c'est mieux
alors l'europe semble hésitante
également face au drame des migrants
méditerranée là où on nous annonce
l'envoi d'une armada assez conséquent
cela dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent mais simplement pour pour
observer ce qui se passait vraiment
utile est ce que vous attendez vous d
une action plus ferme par exemple contre
les passeurs je suis pour qu'on organise
la sécurité des côtes et pour qu'on ne
laisse pas passer n'importe quel en
bague embarcations chargées de pauvres
gens qui ont payé des milliers de
dollars chacun pour aller vers le rêve
l'eldorado européen
donc il nous est un avion militaire te
seront victimes et je suis pour qu'il y
ait une action militaire encore faut-il
répondre à la question à laquelle pour
l'instant on n'a pas proposé de réponse
et qui est que fait-on des migrants qui
sont sur les bateaux et donc elles
résonnent les embarcations alors
jean-pierre en leur intégrant la ramène
sur une côte et moi je défends l'idée
qu'il va falloir nouer des accords ou
imposé des accords avec les pays
d'origine pour ramener les migrants
peut-être pour organiser dans des
régions dans des régions
où ça d'où ils viennent une sécurité à
nantes je pense à la libye je pense
qu'on peut pas laisser le désordre qui
existe dans l'autre côté de la
méditerranée jean pierre raffarin est à
votre place la semaine dernière françois
baril et lui il prévenu il préconise
l'installation dans les villages
désertés en france de deux ou trois
familles par exemple que pensez-vous
françois bayrou de cette proposition de
l'ancien alors je suis très rare que je
sois en désaccord avec jean pierre
raffarin parce que be tuellement on a en
raison de de l'histoire on a des
réflexes qui sont assez proches mais
toute idée qui consiste à laisser penser
que le les campagnes françaises après
les villes françaises vont être comment
dirais-je organisé pour que s'installe
dès complet des groupes de migrants et
pire encore serait repeupler
l'expression entre nous si vous y
réfléchissez est horrible parce que vous
voyez ce qu'elle implique
je suis en désaccord avec ça alors 1
je considère que nous avons tous une
responsabilité qu'on peut pas laisser
l'italie tout seul dans la rue et la
grèce parce que la grèce aussi être
victimes de vagues de migrants on peut
pas laisser l'italie et la grèce seul
face à cette responsabilité de d'avoir à
affronter des déplacements de population
simplement parce qu'elles sont aux
premières loges c'est ça la vérité donc
je pense qu'on a une responsabilité oui
je pense que lorsqu'il s'agit d'asile
mais l'asile par rapport aux vagues de
migrants c'est très très peu l'asile
politique en raison le et vite
évidemment le l'essentiel des migrants
ce sont des migrations économiques
c'est de l'émigration c'est des gens qui
arrivent plus à vivre chez eux cm 50 0
en europe et des responsables à la
commission dire justement il faut que
l'europe ouvre ses frontières c'est une
condition indispensable à sa croissance
les gens pour des oiselets gens qui
disent ça de cons
rennes pas comment les peuples vivent
quels sont les émotions qu'ils
ressentent et moi j'ai une certitude
c'est que la version non c'est que la
question de l'immigration est une
question de l'acceptation des migrations
ou des migrants ou des who de l'asile
est une question d équilibre de
population lorsqu'il y a une part
modérée de la population lorsqu'il ya un
équilibre à ce moment là c'est bienne
accepté et si tout d'un coup vous avez
des groupes très nombreux qui arrivaient
des déséquilibres de population qui se
créent alors vous avez des rejets et la
couleur de la peau ne fait rien à la
faire alors vous pouvez avoir des
groupes qui sont ethniquement très
prochain et puis tout d'un coup vous
vous sentez complètement agressée dans
votre manière d'être dans votre manière
de vivre les peuples sont comme ça je
prends un exemple très étrange sans
doute les mahorais à mayotte et les
comoriens c'est absolument les mêmes
ethnies
c'est les mêmes origines familiales
c'est les mêmes communautés sont les
roms
et lorsque des déplacements de comoriens
importants ont lieu alors des scènes de
racisme et des sentiments de racisme se
développe au sein de la population
mahoraise et vous voyez bien que ce
n'est pas seulement une question d'
ennemi de couleur de peau de religion
comme on lui dit c'est aussi un
déséquilibre qui vient du nombre
lorsque le nombre devient trop important
la réaction de rejet et y mettait alors
deborah claude de la fp va nous
rejoindre maintenant on va notamment
évoqué l'entrée en campagne de françois
hollande vous l'avez observé alors si on
suit les élections des élections
municipales partielles de ce week-end à
droite progresse mais le chef de l'état
lui apparemment ne cède pas un pouce de
terrain paul bouffard
record battu une douzaine de
déplacements en seulement quelques jours
une campagne qui ne dit pas son nom un
président impopulaire pourtant candidat
alors pour revenir dans le jeu à deux
ans de la présidentielle
il faut battre le pavé c'est
relativement
classique les présidents sortants qui
sont un peu usé par le pouvoir et même
beaucoup plus et comme l'est aujourd'hui
françois hollande tente toujours dans
les deux ans qui précèdent le
renouvellement du mandat
voilà deux d'engager un véritable
lifting de leur image politique de
s'adresser aux clientèles électorales
dont ils savent très bien qu elle se
dérobe sous leurs pieds
il est venu le temps de la
redistribution après la rigueur
le président annonce plusieurs mesures
neuf millions de ménages français
verront leurs impôts baisser
complémentaire santé pour les retraités
prélèvement à la source des cadeaux pré
électoraux avec un petit mot revoter
pour moi c'est difficile dans la vie
politique de ne pas voir dans chaque
démarche démarche électoraliste parce
que les femmes les hommes politiques
cherchent à la fois faire partager un
point de vue et en même temps cherche
aussi tu réellement se faire réélire
démarche électoraliste ou pas on ne sait
plus trop dès le jour de l'élection du
président de la république on est déjà
dans l'après puisque les gens se
tournent déjà qui sera le candidat ou la
candidate etc
non je crois pas du tout que françois
hollande le chef de l'état sur dance est
dans cette direction une chose est sûre
françois hollande me sur le rebond de la
croissance il a vécu de l'intérieur la
campagne perdue de lionel jospin en 2002
at il retenu la leçon
françois hollande a une stratégie qui
est un peu commune avec celle de lionel
jospin mais ça ne lui avait pas servi à
grand chose c'est de dire comptons sur
les indicateurs économiques bien j'ose
pas avait cherché à surfer sur des
indicateurs économiques qui étaient
plutôt bons françois hollande cherche à
surfer sur des indicateurs économiques
qui pourraient être bons mais qui pour
l'instant ne le sont pas du tout en
attendant l'inversion de la courbe du
chômage françois hollande distribuer le
coût de la pochette surprise
présidentielle serait estimé à 5
milliards d'euros
voilà deborah claude est avec nous
bonsoir deborah donc sur un chef d'état
en campagne apparemment il est en
campagne françois hollande est ce que
vous c'est ce qui ce que vous constatez
pourront ils ya toujours un aspect
électorale où un mouvement pour essayer
de faire remonter des sondages moi ce
que je crois c'est que françois hollande
auprès des français a perdu son crédit à
jamais et je ne vois pas très bien de
quelle manière il pourrait le retrouver
il a perdu son crédit non pas comme ça a
été indiquée pour des raisons d'image et
qu'il suffirait de faire un lifting de
l'image pour nom il a perdu 13 et 10
pour des raisons de fond parce que il
n'a pas assuré
la mission qui était la sienne de donner
à la france un projet une volonté de la
fédérer et de la rassembler et c'est
parce qu'il n'a pas assumer cette
mission que les français n'ont plus
confiance en lui et vous avez encore vu
ce week end ce jour si la dégringolade
des promesses et dont air et donc le
servir et donc en plus les pochettes
surprises l'expression il est utilisé
mais c'est un leurre c'est n'importe
quoi dans un pays dont tout le monde
sait qu'il n'arrive pas à réduire son
déficit prétendre que l'on aurait de
l'argent pour au contraire faire des
largesses c'est une manière de cagnotte
c'est une manière de prendre les
citoyens pour des gogos et je vous
assure que l'humeur du pays n'est pas à
se laisser gotis est dangereuse qu'elle
fait ou ce qu'il dit aujourd'hui ce
qu'elle promet françois hollande pour
rosser pas pareil du pays
c'est pas dangereux et l'asse c'est
tellement classique
c'est cousu de fil blanc c'est cousu de
grosses ficelles
c'est cousu de câbles de marine donc le
le prétendent redistribuer l'argent qui
n'existe pas sans avoir réussi à
rétablir les conditions dans lesquelles
le pays peut créer de l'emploi de la
richesse de de l'attractivité et
et reprendre ses ficelles qui sont des
ficelles éculés pour moi en tout cas je
ne je ne vois pas ce que ça peut
apporter de bons y compris à lui même
vous parliez des sondages alors pour
vous il est pas en capacité de se
représenter en 2017 quand vous voyez les
choses
il décidera moi la seule chose qui
m'intéresse c'est pas les sondages c'est
le sentiment profond que j'ai de ce
qu'est la situation du pays et la mére
du pays
et aujourd'hui je ne vois pas de quelle
manière
l'intérêt du pays peut se retrouver dans
des recettes éculées comme celle-là dont
le prélèvement à la source
vous avez dit que vous l'aviez proposés
il ya déjà des années oui bah j'ai
défendu l'idée du prélèvement à la
source le prélèvement à la source c'est
comme l'enfer vous savez l'enfer est
dans les détails et la manière dont
s'est organisée c'est pourquoi sagement
j'allais dire ou prudemment ou en tout
cas réalistement le gouvernement annonce
la pwa la source mais ne le fait pas
annonce le prélèvement à la source mais
dit on le réalisera en 2018 sur le real
et montagne et si on le réalise en 2018
c'est après les élections et donc tout
ceci c'est de la fausse monnaie
alors passons de l'autre côté de
l'échiquier politique
il y avait eu des déclarations récemment
de nicolas sarkozy sur les migrants dont
on parlait tout à l'heure
mai prochain une partie une partie des
hommes et femmes politiques sur des
migrants qui sont à comparer à une fuite
d'eau est ce que ces déclarations ça
vous encourage à soutenir à aider alain
juppé est ce que ça vous renforce dans
cet âge je n'ai je n'ai jamais changé
d'avis depuis
une longue période sur ce qu'est encore
sur ce sujet l'intérêt du pays mais
peut-être il faut regarder attentivement
pourquoi est ce que ces phrases sont
choquantes
quelle est la raison qui a ému à ce
point elle vous en soit l'opinion
oui je vais vous dire pourquoi vous avez
entendu les spectateurs qui étaient là
manifestement on rit oui oh mais vous
savez peut hélas une salle partisane on
peut l'entraîner
ap le dire beaucoup de choses même
excessive et à les faire rire de
beaucoup de choses même triste parce que
c'est l'ambiance des meetings et c'est
pourquoi le comment des âges l'aspect
partisan des choses est évidemment
extraordinairement dangereux
alors pourquoi ces choses c'est choquant
parce que ça parle de personnes humaines
de femmes d'hommes d'enfants de jeunes
comme de choses une fuite d'eau un tuyau
crevé et vous voyez bien que mettre sur
le même plan et dans la même phrase
des destins humains et des destins
humains qui sont souvent tragiques et
des choses domestique comme une fuite
d'eau une fuite d'eau sale qui se répand
dans une maison il ya là quelque chose
qui est extraordinairement troublant et
tout le monde le sont instinctive
instinctivement et c'est pour toi je
trouve que les responsables politiques
gagneraient à prendre les choses par le
haut venez un troublant la veut dire
quoi vous pensez de la part d'un autre
qualificatif
non non je pense je pense que c'est
hélas infiniment blessant pour beaucoup
de gens qui instinctivement ce sens que
si ces gens s'en vont c'est pas pour le
plaisir
si ces gens fuient si ces gens paix
toute leur fortune et au delà tout ce
qu'ils ont pu amasser et au delà pour
aller mourir en mer c'est pas parce
qu'ils sont uniquement mal intentionnés
de nom c'est parce que le la vie les
conditions de vie qui leur sont faites
sont des conditions de vie terribles
pour pour pour eux et donc au moins on
peut pas en parler comme s'il s'agissait
d'une fuite d'eau de vaisselle vous
comprenez est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec manuel valls qui a dit tenir que
l'islam allait être un enjeu électoral
qu'il le regrettait il le regrettait
c'est ce qu'il a dit mais que ça allait
être un enjeu on en fait un enjeu et je
suis en désaccord profond avec cette
manière de regarder les choses mais je
voudrais aller un peu plus loin
n'est ce pas la société française
spécialement parce qu'elle est en crise
mais aussi parce qu'elle est en butte
des crispations à des à des mouvements à
des tremblements de terre comme beaucoup
de sociétés en europe et dans le monde
cette société française elle est fragile
et il n'y a rien de plus simple que de
faire flamber les détestations des uns
contre les autres et de les faire
flamber sur les questions de mode de vie
et de religion c'est encore plus facile
que le reste
vous savez que j'ai écrit des livres
plusieurs livres sur les guerres de
religion et c'est pour moi un sujet de
réflexion depuis longtemps et henri iv
qui a permis de sortir des guerres de
religion un point de repère dans
l'histoire de la france mérite d'être
mise de coton dans la non élective de la
présidentielle dans la place de l'islam
elle ne sera pas mise de côté parce que
forcément il y a des forces qui veulent
qu'ils veulent le faire flamber et moi
je pense qu'il y a là un point
extrêmement important de notre projet
comme pays
nous france il ya des gens qui
prétendent que on peut opposer dresser
les uns contre les autres et il ya des
gens et j'en serai qui prétendront que
l'avenir du pays
c'est au contraire que nous prenions
enfin conscience que nous allons devoir
vivre ensemble de l'upm que les petits
garçons à la jupette attendait que
montreuil et vous pouvez aussi nommer
les internats passe alors que leur
laissez moi parler du fond que les
petits garçons les petites filles qui
sont sur les bancs de l'école dont
peut-être en parlera un peu plus tard
qu'ils vont devoir vivre ensemble que
tous ceux qui prétendent que l'on
pourrait faire partir ceux qui sont là
ont la nationalité française ont grandi
chez nous sont nés là et que et qui au
fond paie des impôts aussi un qu' on
pourrait les faire partir on pourrait
les chasser on pourrait les jeter à la
mer comme on l'a dit c'est pas sur la
lenteur cela on parle d'intégration et
maintenant même deux notions d'assimiler
laissez moi finir seul à ceux qui
prétendaient défendre cette thèse
cela non seulement nuisent à l'intérêt
du pays mais en plus ce sont des
menteurs
parce que évidemment ce n'est pas ce qui
se produira alors qu'on cultive ou qu'on
entre dans un mouvement de compréhension
mutuelle en expliquant un conte va
devoir vivre ensemble et 2 que pour
vivre ensemble il faut faire des efforts
tout le monde doit faire des efforts et
en particulier les forts
de ne pas blesser les uns ou les autres
par exemple il ya une phrase que je
considère comme terriblement malheureuse
dangereuse et même les combats très
sensé qui a dit qu'il fallait que les
églises soient transformées en mosquées
là c'est le recteur de la mosquée il l'a
dit dalil boubakeur je pense que cette
phrase est monsieur boubakeur n'est pas
en cause c'est quelqu'un que je respecte
elle savait qu'ils à dire mais cette
phrase là est une phrase de nature à
mettre le feu d'accord vous comprenez
bien que quand vous êtes attaché à votre
religion à votre foi quand ou même quand
vous n'êtes plus très attaché mais que
c'est votre pays vous prenez le lieu le
plus sacré le plus consacré et vous
prétendez qu'on peut évidemment gommer
tout cela dans un dans un édifice dans
tout le monde voit qu'il est un point de
repère pour un village où pour un
quartier où pour notre histoire
d'essayer de nature à mettre le feu et
tout ça ça demande tous à toute cette
situation exige qu'il y ait des
responsables qui soit responsable des
responsables qu'ils soient prudents
avisé qui est un jugement équilibré est
qu'ils ne se lancent pas dans des
improvisations quand vous voyagez
beaucoup plus vivement que l'épiscopat
qui n'a pas réservé ce type de réal et
le beau bakker
je suis absolument certain que je réagis
pour servir la paix civile et l'entente
dans le pays à partir du moment où on
alimente ce genre d'idée que au fond on
peut remplacer ce que nous sommes par
autre chose
à ce moment là vous fait flamber et je
le dis comme quelqu'un qui est croyant
qu'ils aiment la laïcité qu'il a des
sons qui respecte les croyants et je
n'ai pas rencontré depuis que cette
phrase a été prononcée un seul musulman
qui ne me disent mais c'est parce qu'on
veut alors alors le vivre ensemble entre
partis politiques puisque vous êtes en
train de dire il faut bien s'entendre
est ce que vous allez vivre avec les
républicains pour les régionales qu'est
ce que vous voulez dire
alors est-ce que vous allez en est
extrait que vous trouverez la
circulation votre alliance entre rudy et
donc les républicains le terrain c'est
déjà le cas sur le terrain ben vous
voyez bien vous voyez bien ce ce qu'il
en est il y à des forces politiques et
kick théo semprun qui pensent que elles
sont dans une alliance obligatoire avec
parler de lui dit la presse oui je parle
de lui dire en tout cas d'un certain
nombre de responsables de l'ue lit parce
que sur le terrain c'est pas du tout ça
sur le terrain
alors alors sur le terrain c'est pas du
tout ça et donc il ya des gens qui
considèrent dans les appareils que bon
on peut pas faire que il faut une
alliance obligatoire et en rhône-alpes
et les gens vous le modem d'énigmatiques
leur vie et nicolas sarkozy dit cette
alliance ne se discute pas et à partir
du moment où
voulais être sur une liste avec nous
vous vous engagez pour l'avenir à nous
soutenir et en particulier à participer
à l'organisation de cette primaire
voilà c'est c'est eh bien ce n'est pas
ma conception de la conception à moi
c'est que il y a deux forces politiques
distinctes pas un amalgame deux forces
politiques distinctes que la nature du
centre s'il veut exister et d'être
indépendant qu'il peut nouer des
alliances mais qu'il ne peut pas entrer
dans une soumission est alors comprenez
ce loisir
oui non mais mais j'entends tout à fait
pour moi il y a incompatibilité entre
l'idée d'indépendance d'un courant
politique plein et entier et la
soumission à l'ordre et une dernière
question concernant la région
rhône-alpes à ce que l'on s'interroge
sur ce que vous voulez faire par rapport
à laurent wauquiez
et bien c'est très simple à faire
barrage nous avons nous avons investi et
désigner une paire à une personnalité
jeunes intéressante attrayante respecté
qui s'appelle patrick vigneau là et qui
est en train de réunir des équipes pour
moi un à bord on voulait faire barrage à
laurent wauquiez d'un mot mais est-ce
que vous m'avez entendu utiliser cette
expression non mais alors c'est vous
vous avez c'est vous qui utilisez parce
que vous essayez de me faire dire
quelque chose j'ai refusé de vous dire
j'ai servi un mot sur le rôle c'est de
choisir et la gcc dernier en rouge
aurait préféré deux lois la candidat
michel barnier qui avait l'expérience
l'enracinement et la capacité de
représenter cette région surtout de la
représenter par l'ensemble européen qui
reno mais c'est leur avocat n'a alors
pas lui il pas qualifié pour ce type de
fonction et pour le reste à vous voyez
je je réserve
je réponds aux mises en demeure
je veux dire c'est très simple les
habitants de la région ont droit à ce
qu'on leur propose un choix une une
accord une une proposition différente
une sensibilité différente pour l'avenir
de la région
rhône-alpes et c'est ce que patrick
mignola est en train de faire bien
compris voilà merci à doha voilà mais en
ile de france à l'eure avait réussi
puisque nous avons comme vous savez nous
avons l'île de france des équipes est un
courant politique qui est fort et
marielle de sarnez et à paris yann
wehrling pour l'acier ensemble sont une
équipe qui est de nature à porter ce
projet alors de deux choses l'une ou
bien l'ump voudra qu'il y ait une
entente à sur des bases dont on
discutera sur la liberté qu on assumera
et à ce moment-là peut-être d'entente
pourra se faire ou parce que il n'ya pas
de guerre avec madame pécresse
ou bien elle ne voudra pas et dans ce
cas est bien là car opposeront le choix
aux habitants les régions avaient évoqué
maintenant votre combat contre la
réforme du collège avec donc les
renforts que je signalais au début de
l'émission l'académie française avant
d'accueillir perrine tarneaud faussetés
saint geniès mais le point sur votre
combat avec une pétition à la clé c'est
la dernière salve contre la réforme du
collège une déclaration de l'académie
française votée à l'unanimité qui
dénonce l'affaiblissement des
disciplines fondamentales
la grogne contre cette réforme est donc
loin de s'essouffler les attaques fusent
de toutes parts de la tribune de
l'ancien président valéry giscard
d'estaing dans le monde vendredi dernier
à l'apic dimanche de l'ancien ministre
de la culture
la socialiste aurélie filippetti il ya
un grand débat qui est né de cette
réforme du collège qui pose un certain
nombre de questions sur n'a par exemple
les humanitaires classique grandier le
latin le grec ou la suppression des
classes bilangues je regrette que
les pas eu un retour en arrière sur
scène je trouve négatif trois anciens
ministres de l'éducation nationale de
gauche de droite et du centre jean
pierre chevènement luc ferry et françois
bayrou ont même co signé cette pétition
pour un collège de l'exigence en trois
semaines elle a récolté plus de 27 mille
signatures
objectif de cette fronde revenir sur les
trois principaux axes de cette réforme
de l'organisation du collège la
suppression des classes bilangues la
suppression des options latin et grec
telle qu'elle existe actuellement
l'apprentissage d'une deuxième langue
dès la 5e
une pétition balayé d'un revers de main
par najat vallaud-belkacem la ministre
de l'éducation nationale ils ont déjà
dit leur hostilité et leur opposition
il n'y a rien de bien surprenant ou de
bien nouveau
nous ce qui nous importe en effet
aujourd'hui c'est de continuer de faire
en sorte que à la rentrée 2016 le
collège soit véritablement rénové pour
faire réussir davantage d'élèves et donc
pour cela nous accompagnons nous formons
les équipes éducatives faire en sorte
que tout le monde soit prêt en temps
utile pour la ministre le calendrier est
donc déjà tout tracé concernant la
réforme de l'organisation du collège
le décret d'application a été publié le
19 mai dernier
elle s'appliquera dès la rentrée
scolaire 2016 la réforme des programmes
elle n'est pas encore tranchée
l'opposition dénonce un passage en force
aujourd'hui madame najat
vallaud-belkacem demeure complètement
sourd à tout ce qu'on peut lui dire
complètement sourde c'est terrible je
pense que l'école la république ça peut
être
l'école de tous elle devrait écouter le
parlement il est clair que l'engagement
que nous prenons ce sera si jamais si
par malheur cette réforme était mise en
oeuvre en 2016 bien nous reviendrons sur
cette réforme
évidemment la réforme du collège
s'annonce donc comme l'un des thèmes de
campagne de la prochaine présidentielle
voilà pernaut est avec nos perrine vos
questions sur ce sujet âprement débattus
donc est ce que vous prenez vous aussi
l'engagement c'est la droite qui sont
arrivés au pouvoir en 2016 en 2017
pardon de revenir sur cette réforme du
collège vous voyez exactement ce que
nous étions en train de dire à propos
d'autres sujets c'est exactement le
phénomène c'est à dire que au lieu
d'écouter de comprendre d'entendre et de
rassembler on passe en force et comme on
pense en force
évidemment ça va devenir un sujet
électoral ça va devenir un sujet de la
campagne est évidemment non c'est en
général c'est l'attitude du gouvernement
général et donc du président de la
république parce que derrière le
gouvernement
tout ça évidemment n'a pas pu se faire
sans que françois hollande donne son
blanc alors peut-être qu'il n'a pas lu
ou pas fait attention mais il devrait
jeu j'ai déjà dit cela à un micro si
françois hollande m'entends
qu'il demande à quelqu'un de son équipe
d'aller lire sur la pétition que nous
avons signalé pour un collège de
l'exigence point fr qui lie lire les
commentaires il ya des milliers de
commentaires
et ce sont des commentaires de gens qui
engagé dans l'enseignement sont plus
généralement de gauche qu'ils ne sont du
centre ou de droite est le leur
indignation
le sentiment d'être méprisés parce que
derrière tout ça au début en tout cas
pendant longtemps le gouvernement indien
collège délégué une pétition pour un
collège de l'exigence de l'exigence sa
récente de la ministre c'est quoi c'est
un nivellement par le bas
oui de ce manège là c'est le choix
d'empêcher les parcours différents le
collège que nous avions bâti j'ai
moi-même été comme vous savez à
l'origine de textes de cet ordre c'est
moi qui le ministre de l'éducation et
remis le latin en 5e et le grec en
troisième qui est créé des options ou
des cheminements particulier pour les
langues vivantes qui ai mis des études
au collège etc qui est créé les stages
pour entreprises les stages en
entreprise en troisième vous les recevez
chaque année plusieurs donc et donc
c'est moi qui les ai créé pourquoi
c'était l'idée que bien sûr on est dans
le même établissement
c'est ce qu'on appelle le collège unique
fois y avait plusieurs collèges le
collège unique sein s'est justifié mais
que nous n'allons pas pour autant vers
le collège uniforme
nous allons vers un collège qui peut
être différenciées en fonction des goûts
des attentes et des aptitudes
l'acquisition des savoirs dans une
situation d
mais au paiement non vous voyez que vous
vous contredisez là la vérité des choses
c'est que en supprimant ces options là
vous imposer un parcours uniforme et
vous n'avez plus la possibilité
quel que soit votre milieu d'origine
sociale culturelle
vous n'avez plus la possibilité de
choisir des parcours qui vont vous
conduire aussi loin que possible
aussi loin que si vous aviez eu la
chance de naître dans un milieux
culturellement favorisés alors c'est qui
veut dire que c'est socialement honteux
ce que ça veut dire que noront cette
chance que ceux dont les parents auront
les moyens de payer ou de l'enseignement
privé ou des cours particuliers et bien
ceci est une atteinte profonde au pacte
qui est au coeur de l'éducation il
arrive le combat oui je vais poursuivre
le combat nous avons le suivre nous
allons organiser des événements à la
rentrée je suis pas sûr c'est très
important ce qu'on vient de voir dans le
reportage
l'académie française après paris a pris
position mais ce qui est important c'est
qu'elle a pris présent connu parfois
pour ses positions conservatrices
oui mais on m'accuse quelquefois d'être
conservateur
je suis conservateur de tout ce qui
marche bien je suis même farouchement
conservateur pourquoi pas dire que
l'école devient indépendant je suis r
vous l'avez rappelé d'ailleurs eh bien
c'est exactement s'est excusé moi ce à
quoi on s'attaque
c'est ce qui fait que des enfants venus
de milieux défavorisés peuvent avoir
accès aux meilleurs à ce qui amène le
plus loin c'est ça qu'on supprime et
c'est la raison pour laquelle deux cela
je m'affirme de cette possibilité de
cette liberté donnée à tous les enfants
d'avoir des parcours exceptionnel
c'est de cela que je m'affirme
défenseurs et l'idée qu'on va mettre
tout le monde au même pli pour empêcher
il ya des textes 1 je pourrais citer
pour empêcher ces enfants là qui veulent
avoir un parcours
découverte de deux réussites talent
différentes qui ont des aptitudes des
talents de la curiosité de la tente de
la volonté de travailler de leur faire
faire un chemin ça pour moi c'est un
point absolument central 2 du projet de
société que les uns portent et les
autres combats alors il reste 3 minutes
et j'ai évidemment plein d'autres
questions posées premièrement faute
françois bayrou est ce qu'il faut faire
la place en politique en limitant à 70
ans l'âge limite pour présenter à une
élection j'ai jamais été partisan des
limites d'âge
excusez moi de vous dire que dans
l'histoire vous essayez de réfléchir à
de gaulle et churchill
le président israélien shimon peres et
dieu sait que ça n'était pas un homme
politique que ce n'est pas un homme
politique de deuxième plan vient de
quitter le pouvoir a 90 ans
le président de la république italienne
giorgio oui j'y viens je cite ce dernier
cri giorgio napolitano qui a permis à
l'italie d'échapper au chaos créé par
berlusconi
cela et c'était il ya quelques mois cela
napolitano
il avait 90 1 donc de ce point de vue là
je trouve qu'il est stupide de limiter
la liberté de choix d'un peuple
lorsqu'il ressent le besoin il est assez
grand pour dire celui-là je n'en veut
pas et celui là oui en revanche limité
jetons veut justifier qu'on limite le
nombre de mandats dans le temps parce
que ce que je trouve juste c'est qu'on
oblige à se renouveler le monde des
responsables politiques
j'ai occupé plusieurs fonctions au
politique et j'ai toujours été
finalement avec la réflexion et faisant
le bilan
j'ai toujours pensé que c'était bien
d'être obligé de changer de fonction
intervalles réguliers
donc disons trois mandats c'est un
maximum et ça serait bien qu'on limite
le pays est proposé mais moi pourrait
rechercher toute déclaration
jamais été favorable à ce sujet je vous
regardez tout à l'heure vous regardiez
la séance au sénat où dix ans fuit en a
marre de cette lenteur c'est plus
possible
est ce que pour 2017 les programmes à la
présidentielle ça va être une énorme
réformes institutionnelles et notamment
revenir sur cette procédure
parlementaire
je lui dis aujourd'hui qu'elle est
proche je le souhaite je pense que la
procédure parlementaire est totalement
inadapté à la réalité du pays
je pense aussi que l'une des questions
il ya des moments où on réfléchit plus
on radote et donc le je pense que une
des raisons de de la rupture entre les
citoyens et les pouvoirs c'est que les
pouvoirs parle et n'agissent jamais et
je pense qu'il est indispensable que
l'on puisse avoir une réactivité des
institutions et une vérité des
institutions quand vous pensez que la
moitié du peuple français n'est pas
n'est pas représenté en tout cas
représenter dignement convenablement
dans les instances délibérantes dans le
parlement
tout ceci est me semble-t-il oui le
modem présente au sénat il est
représenté à l'assemblée mais pas à la
hauteur de ce qu'ils représentent dans
le pays vous prenez il nous est arrivé
il m'est arrivé il est arrivé à marine
le pen la même chose près de 20%
l'élection présidentielle et au bout du
compte deux députés sur six ans baba
auriez bien que ce que c'est pas juste
merci donc il faut une loi électorale
juste et un changement de la pratique
politique qui permette à la décider vite
encore un enjeu pour dominer 7 merci
perrine merci françois bayrou la semaine
prochaine notre invité sera jean luc
mélenchon bonsoir à tout ça très vite